chapter 15
is on multi-objective least squares
this is an extension of least squares in
practice it turns out we're going to
very quickly reduce it to the standard
least squares so we know how to do it
handle it mathematically but it's very
very useful in practice
so we'll start by saying what the
multi-objective least squares problem is
so here's the problem what we have is
we're supposed to choose an n vector x
that's no different from least squares
but the difference is now
instead of having one least squares
objective
uh or norm squared objectives we
actually have k of them so i have
you know norm a1 x minus b1 squared but
all the way up to norm akx minus bk
squared
so i've k different things that i want
small
okay now here a
i is an mi by n matrix they can have
different numbers of rows and bi of
course is an mi vector
and we refer to the ji as the objectives
in
a multi-objective optimization problem
another name for that is a
multi-criterion problem
because you have k things you care about
the only thing that's absolutely settled
is
you'd like all of them to be small so
that's the main
that's the only thing you agree about
but we haven't yet said like which is
more important than the others
that's coming okay now of course in this
case you know we know how to
if if i asked you to minimize j1 uh you
would know how to do that that's least
squares uh
j2 or j3 um now what we want all of them
small so that's that's how we're gonna
that's what we want to do that's the job
here
okay now here we're going to follow a
very traditional approach
the traditional approach when you have
multiple criteria is to actually
add them up multi-objectives is you add
them up with weights
so we're going to form a master
objective called j
and it is going to be a a
linear combination of the
uh objectives for the k problems so
that's j1
up to jk and these weights lambda 1
through lambda k they have to be
positive
that wouldn't make any sense if they
were negative because that would be an
encouragement to you
to make that one big we want all of them
small so
we're going to this is this is going to
be our so-called weighted sum
objective and some people refer to this
as a scalarization
of our multi-criterion problem so our
original criter
our original problem has k different
things we care about j1
j2 up to jk what this says is that
we're going to scalarize it and we're
going to say we're going to get some
weights and we're going to form a single
scalar number j okay
now here i can i could multiply all
these weights by any positive number i
like and nothing would happen
it wouldn't change it doesn't change the
solution it does change the value of the
js but it doesn't change the solution
um so it's very common to take lambda
one
to be one um and if it's not one i
simply divide every
all of my other weights by lambda one
and i get a new set of weights where the
first one is one um and in that case
people refer to j1
as the so-called primary objective right
and usually that's the thing that you
really actually care about
being small and the others are things
are more like desiderata like if
possible please make them small
okay and we can interpret the lambdas
um it is lambda i is
how much you care about j i relative
to the primary objective so if lambda is
it says it really it irritates me 5
times more
for j5 to be large than j1
if it's 0.5 that says it's half it
irritates you half as much
um and so these these these parameters
lambda one through lambda k
uh or they're sometimes called hyper
parameters um
and they're gonna they're gonna be
different and we're gonna see that we're
actually gonna
you know in in practice you'll choose
different values we'll see about that uh
momentarily or in applications
um now an important special case of this
is the so-called by criterion problem
that's where
k equals two uh and that means you have
just two two
things you want small you want a one x
one
a one x minus b one norm squared plus
lambda times a two x minus b two squared
and so
here lambda is literally how much
the second objective irritates you
compared to the primary objective which
is
norm a1x minus b1 squared
okay now it turns out now here we just
said this is the objective
and now we would say okay what we're
going to do is we're going to minimize
this weighted objective
now we could do that it turns out that
we can easily using some tricks from
matrices and vectors immediately reduce
it to a least squares problem whereupon
we know the solution and we don't have
to actually
re derive anything at all so here's
where you do it
we're going to write that least squares
objective as
uh this so this is lambda 1
norm a1 x minus b1
squared plus and then
the last one which is lambda k times
norm
a k x minus b k squared
okay so that is our that's j here
and it turns out we can write j this way
uh well why is that let's walk through
it um
this is a stacked vector here of course
now the norm squared of a stack vector
is the sum of the norm squares of the
vectors themselves
that's clear because this is just well
okay that's that's
that that's complete that's clear okay
but the norm squared
of like for example this first stack
vector
the lambda comes out the square root
lambda 1
comes out as lambda 1. and so
this gives you this this first term
gives you exactly that
right and this last term gives you
exactly that
okay um now i'm going to write this
objective here
i'm going to write it as simply this as
a least squares objective
i'm going to say that j which is our
weighted sum multi-criterion least
squares problem
objective i'm going to write it as norm
a till the x
minus b tilde where a tilde and b tilde
are these things which are obtained by
stacking the original data
and applying uh the square root of the
weights right so
this is a tilde and that's that's b
tilde so it looks like that
um well but look if i walk up down the
street and i say please minimize
this you know how to do that that's
you've known that for
for two chapters now you know how to do
that um
and the solution is just you know a
tilde transpose a tilde quantity inverse
a tilde transpose b period that's
assuming that the columns of a tilde
are linearly independent which we're
going to so
so what this means is we've reduced this
multi-criterion
this scalar this weighted sum
minimization problem
to a completely standard least squares
problem and we know how to do it
okay so you can work it out i mean
it's good enough just to say it's that
uh or you could write it this way if you
like
a dagger b i mean a tilde i should say a
tilde dagger b
um it's the same same thing
but you can write it out this way which
is actually kind of a beautiful thing it
says
i mean okay very roughly speaking the
least squares solution
is you know a transpose a inverse a
transpose b
and what this does is it actually
basically splits the
numerator and denominator i'm speaking
very roughly because these are matrices
and vectors but
you know the numerator is something like
this thing here and you can see it just
forms a weighted sum of the
numerators and it says you take away the
sum of the denominators now
it's a matrix so but it's you know if
it's inside an inverse that's something
like a denominator
so that's it now you can calculate this
via
you know qr factorization of a tilde
lots of lots of ways to solve
this problem um now an interesting thing
is that each of the objectives
alone could be wide or have dependent
columns so that we'll see examples of
that
and now of course stacked when you stack
them to form a tilde
that has to have linearly independent
columns but the individual ais do
not have to okay
now the by criterion
problem right let's let's take one we're
just going to look at two for now
okay so we have j1 and j2
we're going to minimize j1 plus lambda
j2 remember that we can always just
set the first lambda equal to 1 and call
the first objective the primary
objective so we're going to do that here
and then what's going to happen is we're
going to imagine that we're going to
solve this for
many different values of lambda and
we're going to get something called
we're going to call that x hat of lambda
now that's an n vector
and it's a function of this weight
lambda lambda has a very simple
interpretation
if lambda is small it says we really
care much more about j1 than j2
if j if lambda is really big it means
that we really care much more about
j2 than j1 and if lambda is 1 or near 1
it means we kind of care about them
equally and so we'd like you to minimize
the sum
now when you find this point which is
just least squares
we we know that's very simple
then these are these points are what's
called from the by criterion problem
pareto optimal that's named after an
italian mathematician
and uh you know someone who worked in
economics
uh pareto um and uh
here's what it says it says a point x
x hat or x is pareto optimal respect to
j 1 and j 2
if the following fact let me explain it
uh
this way suppose uh somebody says well
i've got an x and someone says oh yeah
well i've got an x2
this is in the context of this buy
criterion problem and then p
then then people say well who's whose is
better my x or your x let's find out
well it depends on the the different
values of j1 and j2
for the two uh for the two proposed
candidate points
right so um now if one person
let me just let me write it out if this
is j1 and j2 and this is
like x and x uh x
and x tilde there you go and if this is
like you know
10 and 8 if x tilde comes along and it's
9 and seven right
then for sure there's no there's no
discussion x tilde is better
why because you care about two
objectives j1 and j2
and xtilde beats x in both objectives
so no discussion we don't have to talk
about lambdas
nothing j x tilde is simply
better period okay now that changes
if this is 11. okay
now you see this sort of a trade-off and
when someone says you know help us
uh help help arbitrate this fight
between
these two people one is proposing x one
is x tilde and we say well let's take a
look at their objectives
um you would say that okay well look in
j one
x tilde beats it's it's lower numbered
it's better
okay but in j2 x is better
so what you would do is you'd say
there's been there's a trade-off here
and the fact is you you can't say which
is better x or x tilde i mean
that's that's the whole point um so the
only thing that's really in
multi-criterion by criterion the only
thing that's really clear
and unambiguous is if my solution
has a lower object all of the objective
values are lower
than i win it's that that's the only
thing that's clear but if some of mine
are worse than some of yours and some of
yours are better than some of mine
i then it's like who knows who's better
who you can't say
so now i can tell you what burrito
optimal means burrito optimal means it's
a point where
no other point can beat you and i'm
going to define
a beating in this context is to mean
that it has
a smaller value of both objectives okay
so
and in fact in economics i think they
refer to this as dominating
right so in this case uh let me let me
restore this to something that dominates
so in this case you would say here that
x tilde
dominates x meaning it's simply better
it's better on both objectives right so
that means to dominate
um and then you'd say a point is pareto
optimal if it is not dominated
by any other vector okay and what that
says
is so here it's burito optimal if
there's no point
z which beats it in both objectives
that's and beat means smaller value of j
j i okay
and now when you ch when you vary lambda
you're going to get what's called the
optimal trade-off curve
you'll get different values of x and
they will have different values of x1
and
sorry different values of j1 of x and
also j2 of x
and they'll change but every single one
will be will will be
a pareto optimal and then this this maps
out what's called
the optimal trade-off curve so we'll
look at some examples
so here's an example we have a1 and a2
are both 10 by 5. b1 and b2 are 10
vectors
and what we're going to do is we vary
lambda over
well this is on a logarithmic scale over
a very large range right so these are
very small lambdas and these are very
large
now what's happening over here and this
just shows you the value this is five
values this is showing you
x hat okay so um now
for ten to the minus four it says that
we really basically care about uh
only only j1 so we presume
that whatever this is this this solution
here these five
numbers correspond to x hat when you
only minimize j one
that i assume conversely when i take
lambda super big
like lamp ten to the fourth that means i
really mostly care about j2 i don't even
really care about j1
okay and here you get these other
numbers they're they're right here
okay and uh i presume
that is the solution of simply
minimizing
norm a2 x minus b2 okay
so that's it now what's interesting is
what happens in the middle
uh and it's actually super interesting
right because it
it i mean if this was just sort of a
line connecting these two
it would not you know it wouldn't be
that interesting but what's interesting
is that weird stuff happens in the
middle
um so let's see uh i mean let me just
mention a couple of things i mean
uh so this is very uh strange right uh
here's
x3 should have the value i don't know
0.05 or something
in the first thing and to minimize in
the second one it should be like minus
0.1
what's weird is in the middle it sort of
goes up and then down again so
the point about and this is a baby
example so the point about this is it's
just not clear
at all what's going on here or why right
um i mean this is it um
here's how they perform um so over here
what we plotted is the same value of
lambdas from uh
10 to the minus 4 to 10 to the four and
uh let's see how that what that does to
j1 of lambda and j2 of lambda well
um here j1 of lambda in fact for you
know basically lambda up you know as
long as lambda is less than around
0.01 j one of lambda is really small
and presumably that's its minimum value
which is i don't know what's called six
and a half i don't care
right six and a half um now on the other
hand when lambda once lambda is big
you're basically minimizing j2 and i
assume
that the solution of that is whatever
that i don't know what that is let's
call that four
okay so it's about four um
[Music]
okay so that's that what what's
interesting is you can see that in the
middle you get weird stuff
um as you start carrying as you move
lambda out this way
you're you're carrying more and more
about
uh j2 compared to j1 and so what happens
is you start doing worse on j1
but but you're doing better on j2 it's
going down like that
um now some people plot this in what's
called a trade-off curve this is this is
this is what people would call a
trade-off curve this is your first
objective
right and this is your second objective
here j2 right
and this is a good way to understand how
this works so
uh i can show you some examples uh
anyway so these are all pareto
optimal point this is the curve given by
the pair the value the trade-off curve
of j1 versus j2 as you vary lambda
and so here it is and it's kind of kind
of cool and people talk about like the
proverbial knee of the curve and stuff
like that that's
so in this plot being
to the left and down is good
because being to the left means you're
beating on the primary objective
down means you're beating on the
secondary objective so
this is the idea these are like these
three these three different specific
ones
um actually you can visualize a lot here
like for example
um if uh if
if i had a problem and i had you know
this point this point this point and
this point
right um and say let's talk about these
four
different uh choices of x right um
so we can say some interesting things uh
we could say
that this one and this one
are dominated right uh dominated
if you want to know who's better who's
better than you you make
you you look at everything that's to the
left and below you because left means
you beat on j1
below you means you beat on j2 so we
look at this and we can see look this
this this point dominates that one and
that means you should never choose that
one
i mean if these are the things you care
about this one is also dominated it's
actually dominated by both of the other
two
but these two are neither as dominated
there's no among the four points there's
no point and so
here the idea would be for example here
if i
made something like this that's a that's
a point we can achieve
all you cannot achieve that that's what
that's what's being asserted here
there's there's no x that would land you
in that region
if you did then this is a big old lie
and that is not the that's not the
optimal trade-off plot
okay so this is the the idea and you
know these ideas have a lot more
application than just least squares
and it's something you'll see in a lot
of classes i'm guessing
but it comes up every time there's an
optimization problem and you care about
more than one thing
you just form a weighted sum and
minimize that
now the way it's used is you use the
weighting
the weights uh as knobs to kind of
achieve what you really want
so that's the next discussion is
um so here's how you would use
multi-objective least squares
the first thing you do is you identify
the primary objective like the basic
quantity you want to minimize like you'd
say i don't know it doesn't
doesn't matter what it is it's this is
the main thing i would minimize
then you choose one or more secondary
objectives
and these are sort of things like if
possible could you make this thing small
or if possible
could you make my decision today look
like yesterday's
because you know it's just that that
encourages smoothness in the decisions i
make
right or i would like you to minimize
the risk of this portfolio
but i would like you to do it with as
few trades as possible
or something i mean with a small trade
vector i should not have said a few
trades because
that's a different problem i should have
said with a small trade vector so
trade as little as possible to minimize
to to also make the risk small so it'd
be things these are the kinds of things
we're talking about
okay now the way this works then is you
uh you tweak or tune the weights until
you like
or at least can tolerate um x hat of
lambda right so that's that that's how
that works
um and the rules are really simple right
that here if if you think j2 is too big
if you're uncomfortable with it increase
lambda 2. let's sorry increase lambda
which is lambda 2.
okay increase lambda that says you're
putting more weight on that second
objective
and when you minimize again it's going
to come out smaller
by the way j1 is going to come out
bigger so
if you think j1 is too big
then you have to decrease lambda right
which is the
the other way to do this right um and
this is this is how this works and
sometimes this is done in an organized
way but more often than not it's just
done by just fiddling around literally
just like this you type in a lambda
you look at the solution run some
simulation or something to see if you
like it
and if you don't you tweak lambda and
then when you get bored you quit and you
say that's my ex
so so this is this is kind of how it's
used uh in
in practice um it'll be much more clear
when we look at some uh
examples which we'll do which we'll do
next